être un Oxford, c'est comme être
invité à 100 soirées à la fois et je
veux aller à toutes, vous savez, dans
quelques années, ces garçons seront derrière de
très grands bureaux.
qui
pensent qu'ils sont ici pour obtenir un diplôme le
club pour atteindre la meilleure université du
monde et 20 000 autres personnes, mais
il n'y a pas plus de 10 dans le
club anti-émeute, le top 10 vous a frappé au total
Chateau Petrus 1976
bienvenue dans la balade
c'est notre heure messieurs
laissez-nous manger jusqu'à ce que nous explosions
buvons jusqu'à ce que nos yeux tombent
ces gens ne sont pas vos amis
pensez que vos hameçons c'est arrivé
vous venez d'être une erreur